[Musique]
ah bah il est probable ce passeport pour
votre information dès le gagnant du
concours lune de miel 1 une semaine
all inclusive pour deux titres dans le
spectacle je déteste sans succès bonjour
à l'hommage
si je peux aider par la gourmette santa
claus comme le pape précise jean paul ii
monde si ce monsieur saucisses n'a pas
de chance
alors on a pensé comme premier parle pas
de la boxe ouais c'est encore moi je
veux juste te dire que je pense est pas
là là là tu veut la récupérer ya pas 36
méthodes à la cud merci pour la chemise
pour le script j'en prendrai qu'un jour
avec au verso
pour les boissons on mélange mais moi de
zombies konkobo moins d'alcool de kyoto
ok bon bras all inclusive passé jean
paul est arrivé gérer mais qui m'a pété
dessus non non non je suis papeete c'est
une bulle de maillots je vois je vois
une femme d'un certain âge certains
d'ailleurs je vois le fameux mur mur
très très très dur suis sûr quant à me
regarder messin a alors lu on drague
comme ça j'ai réglé une fois pour toute
et légal téléphonie allemande avions pas
mal d'atouts
pas rester jean paul c'est pas des
vacances pour moi était jamais de bonne
humeur willow merde ta gueule qu'est ce
qu'elle a ma gueule
arrête de faire le jeune tout le monde
ici tu appelles l'audience n'a pas
compris ça
je suis allé moi c'est ça la sériele
oh